the second question what do you do
before breakfast English lessons help
Afghan evacuees in West London integrate
into the local community for this woman
who doesn't want to be identified after
more than 18 months in a nearby Hotel It
Feels Like Home which is why she won't
leave the area
if they want to send me outside of
London I will continue staying at the
hotel it's better than living somewhere
I don't have any support network or
friends I go to these classes and the
women's group and I'm used to living
here if I'm just sent in the middle of
nowhere it'll be difficult for me to
start from zero again at the end of
April the 8 000 Afghan evacuees still
living in hotel accommodation will be
given three months notice to leave and
it seems if they refuse an offer of
housing which could be anywhere they'll
be on their own at a time when there are
many pressures on the taxpayer and the
housing market it is not right that
people can choose to stay in hotels when
are the perfectly suitable accommodation
is available
at his church in Newport pagnall in
buckinghamshire Pastor Steve Wood
welcomed some of the first Afghan
evacuees to arrive in the UK of course
there are hard choices I would just want
to see the government deliver what it
promised to deliver from day one which
was that warm welcome so you moved here
from the hotel yes Afghan evacuee frazan
and her family were moved from a hotel
into this service department they aren't
part of the controversial Hotel
statistics yet they're still waiting for
something permanent and hope they won't
be forgotten we had a very high standard
of life in the country but we feel here
like a bigger is this how you thought it
would be I don't know that most of
Avalon family who were living with us
and same Hotel some of them shifted to
London some of them shifted to
Birmingham some of them shifted to
Liverpool this announcement is about
Afghan refugees who were evacuated when
they Taliban retook control
but the government has also pledged to
reduce the six million pounds a day
spent housing 45
000 Asylum seekers in hotels including
those who cross the channel in small
boats Lisa Holland Sky News